French president Emmanuel macron being
given the honor of a state visit welcome
by his Chinese counterpart Xi Jinping
one of Europe's most influential leaders
coming to ask China to exert its
influence on Russia to bring an end to
Europe's worst conflict since World War
II
I know that I can count on you to bring
Russia to reason and everyone to the
negotiating table
this was Xi Jinping visiting Russian
President Vladimir Putin last month
since moscow's Invasion more than a year
ago Beijing has stayed neutral and
proposed a road map for a ceasefire and
peace talks most western leaders
including macron have criticized the
plan but the French president has been
one of the more conciliatory voices
among NATO heads of state
two weeks before Russia's Invasion he
met President Vladimir Putin in the
Kremlin and has spoken to him several
times by phone over the past year many
are now watching to see if macron and XI
together can provide a breakthrough
where others have failed
China insists on a peaceful resolution
and is willing to work with France to
maintain the rationality of the
International Community and avoid
actions that could further escalate the
crisis or let things get out of control
in a show of European Unity macro is
accompanied by European commission
president Ursula Von delayan who has
taken a much tougher line on China's
failure to condemn the Russian invasion
the Europeans are looking at the very
least to dissuade China from supplying
Russia With Arms we also count
on China not to provide any military
equipment directly or indirectly to
Russia because we all know arming the
aggressor would be against international
law and it would significantly harm our
relationship
the signing of lucrative trade deals on
this trip is seen as beijing's attempt
to maintain good European relations even
as ties with the U.S sour I hope China
will tell president macron on the one
hand and then tell Madame avondalea on
the other hand that it is absolutely
important to have a European perspective
which may or may not be exactly
identical to that of the United States
Chinese and European leaders hoping
traditionally strong trade links can
lead to a diplomatic breakthrough Rob
McBride Al Jazeera
I speak to Andy Mark he's a senior
research fellow at the center for China
and globalization Think Tank he joins us
now live from Beijing thank you for
joining the program French leader Manuel
macron has urged the Chinese president
Xi Jinping to help stop Russia's war in
Ukraine how optimistic are you that
China can do that given the Kremlin has
already said there are no prospects for
a peaceful settlement and that its
offensive will continue
well of course a party to this and it is
so China of course is not a party to
this conflict and it is uh actually
quite geographically removed from it as
well that being said of course China uh
has an interest
in having a peaceful resolution to this
conflict and I think that's been uh
China's position all along and it is
maintained a position of neutrality as
well that I think positions it well uh
to be uh an intermediary to bring this
you say you say China you say China is
trying to remain neutral that's not
really the case is it because on the one
hand it's openly stated that it's a big
supporter of Russia it's not condemned
the war in Ukraine but on the other hand
it's playing this big role of
international mediator surely you can't
have it both ways
well certainly not having it both ways
and I think we have to separate the
conflict with the relationship with the
parties to the conflict so China
certainly has a strong relationship with
Russia uh it has relationships with
every country almost every country uh in
the world so I think it's important to
make this distinction first of all and
China clearly has not taken a side in
this conflict as some countries have
that claim to want to bring this to a
peaceful conclusion and yet fan the
fuels a fan the fires of conflict by
providing arms uh to the participants of
this conflict so I would maybe uh not
completely agree with your statement
there that China's trying to have it
both ways in fact it is the only country
uh that has not taken a position in this
conflict EU relations with China are
increasingly being dictated by the
Ukraine main conflict rather than
economic cooperation
how much will that be playing on China's
mind
well it's not either or so these are
related uh issues uh opportunities
problems
um but they're also distinct as well so
the conflict in Ukraine of course has a
very direct impact on European security
uh Global Security more broadly
um but these are separate issues and I
think China's also approaching this with
France uh with other European countries
as uh demonstrating commitment to
resolving the Ukraine conflict
peacefully but also uh deepening and
strengthening trade and investment ties
with Europe
I appreciate your time Andy mock senior
research fellow the center for China and
globalization Think Tank speaking to us
there from Beijing